watching Eddie's success
how to be Bittersweet for a guy like you
because you're losing that bittish Suite
it was I can't tell you how proud I am
about my brother there's nothing bitter
about it be honest for a minute I'm
being totally honest it must have been
I'm explaining you why I wasn't all
right
I know my family's history from the boat
when they first brought us over here
right so
to see someone rise above that okay
because before my generation or whatever
I can't look back and go yeah you know
my uncle went to Harvard and then he was
this right no we was you know regular
American black people you know
struggling and getting getting you know
get get ahead and then one of us broke
through the first time I seen my brother
perform on stage uh the feeling that he
gave me
um I could still feel that feeling right
now